here
the only trouble with this one is if
he's let's go if he's not quite with it
when you go like that a lot of people
have been smacked in the in the face
all right it's really just
an Ikea
there all right if you turn it over and
do that really you're bypassing but it's
the same feeling as the coat of guys
with the can
so I've warned you so if I see this big
red line down your face my uh that's why
we took the photos earlier
you just gotta whack it in their face
not in not in an aggressive way
but that's the technique
yeah always watch
this is a nice technique this what you
do is you offer me as soon as you see
the hand going on here you just push it
through a couple more inches and then
you've got Mickey
okay this is for the aggressive people
there sounds a few aggressive ones out
there
right so you it's always tactics you
just let him grab it
might not be enough now to get him
so we're going to go on about that I saw
a side of Sensei many times you know
he'd finish the ski and he'd be here but
he'd tell you if you leave more than a
if you leave as much as a hand somebody
behind can grab grab your jar so there's
techniques from that as well
but there's techniques where if you're
doing Joe Nago look you just push it
through a little bit
should we do this one yeah let's do it I
was going to do the other one I was
going to do one not so painful
push it through down
draw a line straight down his body draw
a line thank you straight down their
body here
keep an eye on him so you move it about
a little bit
over there turn
and I'm going to tell you the honest
truth doesn't work
this last part never worked never as
done it's the demonstration piece it
looks great to The Spectators never
worked he'd never let you fiddle about
all that time it'd be in so much pain
he'd be rolling out and wiggling let me
show you this one works but here look
where you can go you can go over there
you can do lots of things you can't get
behind him
she don't say that should I here give
him a little bit down
and then sand to the ground
that you can do this next bit but it's
just a minute right there right there
while I get you right it's for show if
you want to do it please do so
but but as I say it won't work come on
did you okay that's good that's Joe now
guy not Joe door who we're doing Joe
Dory but just to show you a little bit
of um
just to show you a little bit of uh what
a lot of you are doing is you're you're
standing here you're doing this
you're doing that and you're pulling him
you have to float you know like I've
been saying all day you know flow at the
back foot
you know things have to be smooth
I'm going to stand on the line I'm going
to put it here and then I'm going to
flow it over here
I might move about quite a lot because
it depends where I have to be
to get that
all right
all right and then you apply the power
okay
this one
you know you've seen this and then the
great thing is there's lots of videos
out there
take that leg and you do a little bunny
hop back
they're all Joe nagis not what we're
doing okay so Joe Dory
same thing everything is the same
thing take it don't make a big movement
this isn't going to happen
what take a small one
here
step in here and then hit him with that
there
all right so that's basic mechanics
okay try this one please don't
you can add the attemi or not add the
atemi
okay
so it's good to know where the attemis
are going you know
one's in here where where it hurts and
now the ones just there
all right
so once you've taken them on not on the
Block pointing thrown with the Joe but
anyhow so since he would go hey
the bit that people get wrong
or where they struggle is hey here you
can do but when they take this now
well they take this has to power up
against his elbow
okay if you get it wrong and it goes up
under his armpit
he can either put his weight down on you
or you can't throw them
so that circumference is very similar to
what we were doing with the uh Ken this
morning hey
and because they're pinned up there
they're happy to be thrown usually
anyhow
foreign
so the weakness will be that you're
going if you don't do the atemi what
people do is if they get in because they
want to throw they get it and they try
and lift without
powering that up
you can't power out now
so hence that's why the attempt is
important but you roll that wrist round
to get the pitch so a temmie
hey
foreign